continuin [ __ ] after the next session it
will be great to continue chatting but
let's maybe change gears and let us sow
a stuff you're the next chair right yes
I am
okay so I welcome everyone to the last
session for today new casting Tobit 19
our keynote speaker is Hal Varian is an
emeritus professor in three departments
at Berkeley Business Economics and
information management now he serves as
the chief economist of a company you
might have heard of by the name of
Google and he published numerous papers
in economic theory will speak for 30
minutes about using machine learning and
proxy questions to now cast a public 19
and I present our next speaker after
[Music]
okay thank you could everybody hear me
yeah that's not it good all right so I'm
going to talk me put my slides up here
let's see what I do whiteboard I first
it is now casting sure are you seeing it
not really
oh now we're seeing it to you being it
okay so I'm going to go to present now
casting oh I don't see many well there
it is up there okay this is Ward
everyone yes okay good so let me let me
tell you this is it's more of a story
than a talk but I should tell you it's
highly preliminary don't trust any of it
reflects only the views of me and my
co-author nothing to do with our
organizations and I really mean it
this is an extracurricular activity but
I think it would be interesting for this
group
well obviously there's a lot of interest
in forecasting for code 19 cases there's
a interesting site we stumbled across
called forecast hub for example where
people submit their forecast algorithms
and they use ensemble techniques to
average them together and they're a very
interesting stimulating idea I know
kaggle is doing interesting things lots
of other places and I'll show you one in
a minute or two first I want to say a
word about predictive modeling there's
generally speaking two big approaches
one is what's called structural
estimation where you have a causal model
of what causes what and how quickly it
causes it and you need to use those
models if you want to look at the impact
of some intervention for something ever
you want to do a long-term forecast
usually it has to be a structural model
but there's another approach which is
what we call economic so reduced form
estimation where there you're relying on
correlation and extrapolation looking
for the best fit for the near-term
future so you're doing short-term or
local predictions sometimes known as
nowcasting okay so I'm not going to
touch the first one the first one you
have to know something about the subject
of a lot you have to know some
epidemiology for example but I think
with their reduced form it's a little
bit easier because there are some known
methods that you can use to try to do
short term you know current three days
seven days something like that by
extrapolating past trends so to make a
structural model better you need a
better understanding of the system you
need better science to make a reduce for
model better sometimes you can find
better predictors things that are more
correlated with what you're trying to
predict and that allows you to improve
your performance even if you don't quite
know why okay so you maintain a kind of
agnostic attitude on the reduced form
estimation so here's an example nice
site called coded cast it's from CMU I'm
going to tell you a little more about it
Ronnie Rosenfeld is one of the founders
of this site and
tip cerini is also working that's noted
machine learning person it looks at
county level data uses a number of
different predictors and allows you to
get some estimate of what the near-term
future will look like
so Delphi team and CMU is the Greek
people created it they have a CDC
designated center of excellence for flu
forecasting they've won four out of the
last five competitions for flu
prediction and in February 2020 the CDC
a selfie to help build a model for
short-term forecasting for a hospital
capacity planning's planning for
household capacity at the county level
they use predictors such as doctors
visits hospital mission Google Trends
symptoms mobility metrics etc but one
thing was missing was reported symptoms
because in the flu in the flu monitoring
system we have in the u.s. if you feel
you're sick you go to the doctor
doctors are surveyed about influenza
like illness and so that's a helpful
predictor because you've got this sample
of people who have reported flu-like
symptoms and rioted cerini who is as I
mentioned earlier the co co founder of
this site wanted to create a
self-reported system of sim of symptoms
but how could you do that and the
plausible way is to use a survey and
through a friend of a friend kind of
connection he got to me and I said well
we do have something that's really
helpful in doing this kind of survey
it's called not surprisingly Google
surveys and what happens the way that
works is you create an online survey has
to be very simple single question or
maybe two questions at the at the most
and that goes into online publications
and people complete the questions they
answer the questions in order to access
some premium content so every now and
then if you're browsing something in the
web you might see a invitation to answer
this brief quiz to
see door please answer these this simple
question etc etc what happens is the
publishers the people who host these
surveys they get paid when when their
visitors the readers answer the
questions and you the survey designer
get this very nice aggregated data that
gives you a report on this very simple
service now its users are limited you
can only answer don't it has one or two
questions but it's got a very low cost
per respondent when the order of cents
not dollars has a rapid turnaround you
can survey a thousand people in a couple
days so for certain kinds of questions
it's very helpful and what we did is we
looked at the cdc ili surveys and the
survey that they used was to you or
anyone in your household have a fever of
a hundred degrees Fahrenheit or higher
along with uh sore throat or cough okay
so those were the traditional flu
symptoms in the survey for health
questions since they're obviously very
sensitive we say this is going to be a
health question if you don't want to
answer it click here and then you see
the question and you can say yes no
prefer not to answer and that passed our
privacy review or ethics review all this
stuff and it turns out it was a big help
in forecasting it was a significant
improvement in terms of forecasting a
few days ahead a week ahead than what
we're using previously so it was a big
win it was a fact it was better than any
other predictive variables that they had
but unfortunately there was some second
thoughts about this question when you're
asking do you or anyone in your
household that's a fairly sensitive
wording and so we had to stop the survey
but now here's where it gets interesting
Brett Slatkin who's a co-founder of
Google surveys and designed this tool
said let's use a proxy question and a
proxy question looks like this do you
know of someone do you know of someone
in your community who is sick with a
fever along with a cough shortness of
breath or difficulty breathing okay so
that is not asking a
you or your family it's about do you
know someone in your community and
community is definitely left mmm as
being big all right and this is a term
for this and survey among survey experts
is a proxy question you're asked a
question not about yourself but about
someone else or some other group it was
a big win in fact it was better than the
question that was asked about you and
your family which is really kind of
amazing because it's a more vague
question and you think it would perform
worse but actually it turns out perform
better and I'll show you some numbers
significantly better and we dig into
this proxy question issue it is
relatively commonly used for sensitive
topics like health and finance and so on
and when you think about this problem
the individual data is kind of a
nuisance we don't care about the
individual data we care about the
prevalence of the of the disease in the
population and people may feel more
comfortable responding we're looking
into that now it's cost is much lower in
this accuracy tends to be higher
especially when you have low probability
events so suppose you're going to run a
survey about how many people are
shopping for a new car well what's the
odds that a randomly chosen person is
looking for a new car you buy a new car
maybe every four or five years and so it
might be a fraction of a percent but now
you say do you know of people in your
community that are shopping for a new
car and in that case you're effectively
enabling the respondents to report on a
broader set of people and actually again
you can get more accurate answers by
loosening up the statement of the survey
question and you don't really need to
care about what the proxy question is
measuring if it increases the
performance of your predictive model so
you can check and see ask this
question asked that question see which
one is the best predictor of the outcome
in which you're interested whether it's
buying a new car or whether it's
reporting Cova diseases so think about a
question like do you wear a face mask
that probably would not pass the hurtful
in terms of privacy issue but what
fraction the people in your community
are wearing a face mask that's fine in
general so it may well be that the
second question is a better indication
of what's actually happening than the
first question okay and it's potentially
promising for certain sorts of questions
I never knew anything about this topic
until we kind of stumbled into it but it
turns out I think it can do a lot of
useful things particularly because you
can preserve privacy and gather more
accurate potentially more accurate more
predictive information okay so let me go
into what we actually did and now I'll
describe this performance improvement in
a couple minutes
we had daily county level data on
predictors like doctor visits hospital
myths and so on and we had the survey
data for confirmed cases okay so the
answer to the proxy question I described
earlier the answer is yes
no or prefer not to answer okay so what
do you think you think that the cases as
a fraction of the population should be
related to the answers to that question
yes over yes plus no now if you take
some logs and fiddle with that a little
bit you can get a little regression it
turns out you get an r-squared of 83%
which is pretty high using just the
survey questions so perform very well on
that dimension and this is a picture of
scatterplot of what the actual and the
predicted incidence is this is at a
county level data about 500 counties in
the US and then we also ran an
out-of-sample estimate where we took 75
percent of the data and estimated that
and then forecast the other 25 percent
and that also worked fine I mean really
remarkably well and if you look at how
well we
relative to the previous question when
we asked you or anyone in your household
the r-squared there was about 60% if we
put the household question and the
community question both in the survey it
went up to 78% but if we went to the
community question do you know of anyone
in your community
bla bla bla then you get a 81% r-squared
so it's really quite impressive the
improvement you get from using that
proxy question and my deal is it's
particularly helpful in these sorts of
issues where there's a rare occurrence
whether or not somebody's showing these
symptoms and there's also a significant
privacy issue
so not a panacea of course it's just
another tool in the toolkit but it looks
like it's a pretty useful and robust
tool okay let me tell you a couple of
other things we we did just along the
way there's a nice site out there called
County Health Rankings and roadmaps and
this has I think 2002 oh yeah there it
is 2002 health indicators for 3218
counties in the US of course there's
incomplete data for some of those 3,000
counties and the most useful results
come from looking at the top 60% which
is sort of the top 600 which is about
75% of the u.s. population and here
where you could do these you could look
use techniques used to test statistical
techniques to try to find what the
highest correlations are between the
health indicators and the counties now
I'm being kind of loose in that
terminology but I'll give you an example
to show you what I mean so this is a
model it's called the spike in Slab
model where it chooses predictors that
give you the best prediction of the
outcome which you're interested in these
predictors might be positively
correlated with what you're trying to
predict or they might be negatively
correlated so the positive or a white
bars of
the negative or black bars and so these
are showing you the characteristics of
the county population that are in fact
predicted no causality here just
predicts it but of course they give you
a little hunting ground where you can
try to look at what's what's you know
what the cause of relationship by B well
here for example you're saying that for
predicting the confirmed cases the
ethnic composition is important the
Alaska Native American Indian blacks and
so on if there's a high prevalence of
flu vaycay of flu vaccinations but
percent Asian and so on so this is the
the most important I put that in quotes
the most important predictors of the of
the incidence of these confirmed cases
and if predicting deaths it's a little
bit interesting it's a little bit
different food insecurity driving to
work alone percent Asian income
inequality and so on so I'm sure you've
seen a lot of this stuff anecdotally in
the newspaper reports but this is where
those kinds of statements come from
using these statistical models that help
you find the predictors that are the
most useful in this context now the next
thing you can do is you can look at time
series extrapolation so this is again
just to re-emphasize what I said earlier
we're looking for short-term three-day
maybe seven-day forecasts you want the
term to be long enough you could
actually do something like expanding the
hospital capacity but short enough that
it's going to be closely related to what
you're seeing now it's the nowcasting
term that I mentioned earlier so here's
a picture in the UK I switch to the
aggregate level the actual cases are up
there in the top box the seasonality is
that just the weekly pattern day a week
effect this is all daily data and of
course
presumably the disease doesn't know
anything about days a week but the day
the data is collected on certain days a
week and it may not be collected on the
weekend and you're getting this kind of
pattern that you see in that diagram and
sometimes it shows up and sometimes it
doesn't when you look across countries
because it depends on the data
collection infrastructure and by the way
the data for this is still very bad it's
very noisy data so you do have to take a
lot of this with a grain of salt there's
what the trend looks like and then down
below are the residuals the difference
between the fitted variables were you
including seasonality and the and the
actual outcome now if you run what's
called a lag plot so we look at how well
today predicts tomorrow that actually
looks pretty good because it looks like
today's performance is going to be
somewhat predictive of tomorrow or three
days from now and so the simplest
possible model you can use to describe
that relationship is to forecast
tomorrow based on today so you just say
my guess for tomorrow is whatever we saw
today and that would be appropriate if
the data were a random walk there's that
that's a characteristic of random loss
that the best predictor of what will
happen in the next time period is what
happened this time period now obviously
that's a very naive model but you would
use that as a base model to see how much
you can prove on that one step ahead
forecast and I did the axe I mean you
can go look at these statistical index
statistical issues and there's quite a
big variation on the mean squared error
depending on which technique you use and
the winner in this particular case is
something called the seasonal ARIMA
model which had a significantly better
mean squared error than the other places
so that's good that's how I was
wonderful but unfortunately if you look
at the actual prediction so here's that
seasonal ARIMA
all that I just described and I looked
at the forecast for the next week or so
ahead they're down at the bottom you see
there's huge prediction intervals there
so even though it's a something you can
predict it's still going to be the case
if there's a lot of uncertainty about
doing those predictions even if you
limit yourself to this fairly short term
predictions so what's the summary of my
talk here
proxy questions that's a big plus both
for privacy and prediction I think they
deserve to be studied more carefully a
lot of issues about just exactly how you
word them and and how they are utilized
I think there's a lot of open questions
there but I think it's a valid and
important tool cross-county co-variants
are useful for prediction a lot of these
things we know about demographic issues
and and health can pre-existing health
conditions and show up not only at the
individual level but they show up at the
aggregate county level pretty big
differences in the time series model
forecast they don't all say the same
thing
some are significantly better than
others but of course they're still
pretty uncertain and important message
it comes out as predicting across
geographies counties in our case is a
heck of a lot easier than predicting the
future within a given County but
nevertheless doing those predictions
across counties can be very helpful in
terms of responding to the problem so
for example the last discussion was all
about contact tracing and if you can
forecast there's going to be a surge in
a given area then you can ready your
resources for the human contact training
and try to be there when it's going to
be the most helpful
same thing with hospitalization in terms
of making the capacity available these
relatively short-term forecasts even
though they're not not helpful from a
scientific point of view they are
generally going to helpful be helpful
from a policy
so I will end there and turn it over to
the discussion No thank you very much
hell I mean in the meantime you'll have
the Q&A after miss Alice talk but you're
invited to take a look at the chat and I
guess you could see some of the
questions that people may ask you later
on okay so the next speaker is the
personal guide from the University of
Haifa Faculty of Law and Holly is an
expert on law and competition policy and
on the intersection of law and
competition policy with technology do
you happen to see my slides yes yes can
you see them fine okay great so thank
you so much sorry again you'd better use
the display function too because now we
see the slides and they're like the next
slides as well okay is this good okay
thank you so much and I want to start by
thanking the organizers for organizing
this incredible workshop and I
understand it's just a taste you know a
full we are gonna have later hopefully
this is great so thank you so much and
thank you how for the some really
interesting presentation and it actually
serves as a wonderful example of the two
starting points to my own comment and
the first relates to the importance of
data okay because we all know that data
is a game changer since it allows for
the customization improvement of a
decision making it's very it's valuable
to commercial firms to government's to
individuals just think where we would
have been today probably in Berkeley
physically if we had better data early
on on how the virus spreads and what is
the best way to treat it and who has
contacted it so data is extremely
important
and valuable in and so it's not
surprised that access to data has become
a strategic and valuable assets for
firms and governments alike and I
especially like this quote from Russian
President Vladimir Putin who put it
bluntly which is of course
uncharacteristic for him yeah and he
says whoever leads in AI will be the
ruler of the world okay so so the
question is how do we ensure that we
have good data sets and so this leads me
to my second starting point which is
that at least with regard to some types
of data there are high barriers to
accessing these data and and so this of
course affects our predictive modeling
our ability to make better decisions now
health example was a wonderful example
it related to data collection how do we
get people to provide food for answers
which can then be used to better fight
the pandemic but access barriers can
relate also to other parts of the data
value chain for example to data storage
predictor am sorry is synthesis analysis
and use and such very errors can be of
many kind that can be behavioral once
again I think that the health wonderful
talk is a good example of a behavioral
barrier to collecting data they can be
technological for example if you need a
unique access point in order to get
certain types of data for example are
the effects of certain posts and users
emotional steps they can be economic for
example when the collection of certain
types of data is very costly because it
might be a side effect of a very costly
activity such as oil drilling and you
get a geological in
formation but it's a scientist today
such barriers can also be legal and I
would like to focus on this part on the
legal barriers because I think it's one
of the most important points where law
and computer science meet and this is
part of what we're trying to do in this
workshop so law can either facilitate or
it can block access to data which is
necessary to enable better predictions
and the effect of law might be indirect
or it might be direct there might be
laws that that directly determine or
prohibit outright what can be what can
be collected and but more interesting of
course are those instances in which laws
and regulations affect the availability
of data in indirect in subtle ways that
we do not always realize and of course
lien laws regulating access to data
commonly serve important goals and we
talked about some of them on radio as
well such as human dignity and privacy
and public health extremely important
goals yet we should always ask ourselves
whether such access barriers are indeed
justified whether there are better ways
of achieving our own cheating our
collective goals so to do so and to
answer this question the cooperation
between computer scientists and and
lawyers is there is there needed and
this goes along what katarina suggested
you know in the previous session that
the scientists and computer scientists
shooting for law makers of what types of
data are necessary in order to create
better predictions and also what kinds
of technological solutions can be
offered to some of the problems that
arise that the law tries to remedy okay
and what lawmakers should
as attempt to strike the correct
multifaceted balance given all these
important interests so to drive the
point home okay let me give you four
examples of how laws affect access to
data and thus they affect algorithms and
predictive modeling so the first one is
relatively simple and this is actually a
positive example this is law that
increases access to data and actually
can increase Social Welfare as well so
some examples of this are for example as
laws that mandate data collect data
collectors to port
data to another entity in order to
facilitate competition when data
subjects require this and we see this
for example in England with regard to
financial data banks are required to
transfer to other FinTech or financial
institutions we see that in the u.s. we
try to insurance data and there are many
other examples around the world and
these laws serve important goals they're
designed to prevent locking of data
subjects and to facilitate competition
do they really work there are some
literature that says that not
necessarily always one word I find
extremely interesting is by lamanno and
padilha who say that if if you provide
the same data to large firms in this
into small firms or first with very
large data sets they they already have
algorithms that would know better how to
use the new date especially if you have
economies of scale in the analysis of
date so this is one example another
example I think we all have heard about
this this is the GDP are the general
data protection regulation that was it
was adopted in the EU in May 2018
and and of course this has important
implications well early on its orders
so the gdpr was designed to limit harm
to human dignity by harmful use of
private data and so the goal is
extremely important however there are
already market indications that the gdpr
strengthens the stronger that those that
already have vast data sets gain an
advantage because of some of its
provisions and it limits the ability of
smaller firms to compete effectively it
also reduces the ability to realize data
synergies that may lead to better
products now why is that true there are
many reasons and I'm gonna just name
three but there's a lot of literature
about this which is people are starting
to write about it some people have
written about some aspects even before
so one of the arguments is of course the
privacy paradox where users claim that
they place the high value in privacy but
in practice we see that they are willing
to provide it for extremely small
benefit and why is that important
because the gdpr is based on consents
okay it's partly based on consent so if
the data subject consents to sharing the
data and collecting the data using the
data that's fine so this is the first
point here the second is that the GPR
reduces the ability and incentives to
share data among the firm's and why is
that just let me give you one example of
why you think so for example it imposes
a legal obligations on the data receiver
to ensure the compliance of external
data providers with the gdpr
okay so this creates monitoring cause it
creates a high vetting class that
increased barriers to sharing and and it
and any sometimes would make
internal collection more profitable to
the firm then it would have been absent
their GDP are also there's some work by
Campbell Goldfarb and Tucker which is
indicated that when privacy concerns are
acknowledged data subjects tend to give
consent to collecting their data to
diversified into large firms that they
already know rather than to newcomers
now why do we care about these
accumulative effects we care because
they create higher concentration levels
in markets for data they strengthen they
might strengthen some data and
oligopolies and also you know there have
been a lot of reports in the last two or
three years about the digital economy
and how we can balance you know the
power and and introduce more competition
and all the reports talking about data
truly okay if you have small firms or
media firms that each has their own
dataset the ability to combine would
create larger datasets that would enable
them however if we have laws that reduce
the incentive in to the ability to share
the data then this is no solution to the
concentration problem also it leads to
less tactic data markets and less
synergies among firms third example
Computer Fraud and Abuse Act this is an
American Act it's a federal US law which
makes it illegal to access a website
without a thorough zation and obtain
information even if it is accessible to
the general public there in other words
it provides the website owners the power
to decide who can access the information
even if it is generally open to the
public and such potent gatekeeper rights
limit the ability to reuse otherwise
public data for example let me this was
used yeah in or invoked in order to
suppress users from transferring the
own self created content to completing a
services or to restrict price comparison
tools from gathering the necessary
information so why do we care we care
because it obstructs data flows and it
might be used strategically for a firm
by firms to limit and once again data
flows and to create database or to
entrench database their advantages what
can be done this is in front of the
Supreme Court right now in a case
involving a small start-up high q-- and
there's also a lot excess it's called
the Access Act which is now being
considered which might limit harms by
mandating large platforms to allow
people whether directly or through
intermediaries to download their data
and transfer it to another and the
important part here is the intermediary
okay and we can talk about it later
finally last example data
standardization final example involves
the case where regulation should be
added where it does not exist right now
or it does not exist to - and efficient
expense and the the need for data
standardization comes partly from the
vast amount of things that we have
around the world some people talk about
forty three billion exabyte now it
doesn't that to me it doesn't mean
anything so I looked at you know ways
that people have described it and some
of thanks to characterize and resort to
stacks of reports which reach from the
earth to beyond clutter with all this
data you can imagine this I can imagine
now much of the data is collected an
organizing system which is largely
distributed now this implies that those
who collected they don't have the data
are not necessarily the ones that can
benefit from it most or that the only
ones
that can benefit from their data okay so
an important thing is to allow data
interoperability that possibility
interoperability means that we can
combine different assets however here we
have we have all kinds of obstacles
significant technical obstacles today to
interoperability for example make a dead
make the data uncertainty swear if you
have the data set that somebody else
created you don't exactly know what the
data signifies Mike you have
transformation obstacles where the the
data to not necessarily be combined
because it relates to different factors
that cannot easily be be added into the
database and of course there is a
problem of missing data because I did
not know that you would need this kind
of data and not other times so data
standardization can wait by which I mean
setting standards that relate to the
data value chain can reduce some of
these problems just an example here
reduce the data the missing data problem
by setting data standards for a data
collection the National Coordinator for
health information technology for
example set standards for the collection
of observation regarding patients
allergies I do in order to enable such
learning and predictive
so in some cases where we cannot rely on
the market okay there is a role for
government in order to at least think
whether we need Standardization with is
the best facility and maybe assist in
facilitating even if it's the players in
the money bottom line so long shapes
access to data and it might have
significant effects on algorithmic
learning so we should talk with each
other
thank you Miss Howe this was very
interesting
you know have many replies so we have 20
minutes for questions I'm going to start
with a question for Feldman and if you
want to ask me if you want to ask
questions why don't you just use the
chat to let me know otherwise I'm just
going to call on people from the chat
[Music]
okay thank you so how this this question
was raised by me and by other people too
this is a question of how do you deal
with over accounting so the example I
have is in mind suppose we are all all
people in this room are asked how many
people around you are chief economist
for a company bigger or equal than
Google so so double so so it seems to me
that the performance of proxy questions
really depends on the type of question
and the type of the community and my
question is whether there are techniques
to address like the the over counting
problems and other other problems that
come to mind by using proxy questions
right so remember what we're trying to
do with this answers of these questions
is to predict some other variable to
confirm cases of kovat 19 and we don't
really care for over counting because a
statistical regression the monster
system model we're using will adjust for
that
so it's certainly true you're absolutely
right that the efficacy of this approach
is going to depend significantly on the
kinds of questions that you're asking
but if you stop and think about it think
about a question most people in my
community wear a mask when going to the
supermarket now that question would
probably be helpful in predicting the
incidence of kovin 19 right so is it an
over estimate it would be an under
estimate what does it even mean to be an
over estimate or address but the
question is is it predictive does it
help doing the prediction
I think earlier when somebody said well
when when I posed the question I said do
you know of someone who has it's not
whether you personally know them because
again there's a very delicate difference
there that might affect the accuracy and
might effects might depend significantly
on the kinds of questions you're asking
so I would say be very pragmatic
straight empiricists asked a variety of
questions run a pre survey and see what
it looks like and if it helps doing the
prediction that's right so I guess let
me rephrase my question either a more
rigorous way to identify when a peroxy
question is its predictive well what's
interesting about it is usually the
proxy questions come up when you look at
the statistical literature on this they
come up in cases where they really would
like to talk to the individual but the
individual is at home or the individuals
hard to reach for this for that so they
talk to somebody else in the household
something that would be an example of
the kinds of things but so for those
questions the proxies sort of second
best but the good and the surprising
thing about our little study is that it
turned out we thought it would be second
best but it turned out to be better than
a more accurate question and it turns
out when you dig into the literature a
little bit there you find this same
thing when you have a low probability
event it's better to ask people about
are you aware do you know is it the case
all this kind of loose loose questioning
in order to get an estimate of what that
small probability event is like so
another tool in the toolkit not if
that's something that solves all known
problems thank you ask a question either
Oh answer one of the questions they said
how do you reach what about small
communities that are hard to find well
this is one of the issues that comes up
when you look at County data because
there are counties with millions of
inhabitants and I think the smallest
County has 80 inhabitants it's a little
county in Hawaii and it's very very
difficult to deal with those sparsely
populated places first of all they're
inherently going to be different because
of the sparse population but second of
all they're going to be noisy because
there seemed to be rather special
communities and we can't do anything
about that really
ACEF if you'd like I can answer some of
the questions in the chat about - I mean
so that people will know what I am
okay story yeah Nicole asked about the
unraveling problem with regard to the
GDP era the fact that if I do not
provide the information it might be that
that I will suffer from that because it
would be a negative signaling with
regard to myself I completely agree and
and I think that that was the case even
before the GDP are I don't think the GDP
are changes it so much it goes on at the
DB PR asks what kind of information the
firm can collect and and and how it can
use it professor me know asked about why
not directly ban harmful uses rather
than go along the privacy I think it's a
you know it's a very important question
and one that the answer to it should
also involve them of course technology
experts and them and one of the
questions I would ask here is whether we
can actually prohibit
all these harmful effects with without
protecting our own private information
I'm not sure is a part of it is you know
defining what kind of conduct is harmful
as to take discrimination okay once we
move to a system where there's another
lot of knowledge about this and
different kinds of offers can be made to
different people so even the products
and the services would be a bit
different
what doesn't even discrimination me okay
in such an environment this is a
question we have to think about but
there's also I think beyond that there's
the deeper notions of privacy that I
distinctly do not want many people to
know things about me even if they do not
use it in a discriminatory way or in
order to harass me just the feeling that
many people know many things that but we
might be harmful to my own sense of
course there are people in this group
who know much more about privacy and
then myself so this is my these are my
two cents
maybe one one just comment as another
person who the not a privacy person but
maybe one way to rephrase martyr minutes
question is as information becomes
increasingly more important and I think
finally demonstrated that maybe privacy
becomes too narrow a prism through which
to regulate all those activities that
you know when you know on the good side
or the bad side that will arise out of
information maybe we should deal with
the monopoly of the privacy acts
okay any questions the organizer is
maybe there's something you'd like to
add I want you to ask hell about the
type of this is a this this goes beyond
your presentation and into your role as
the chief economist in Google my
question is to what extent there or
other tools that has been used by Google
in order to to predict outbreaks or you
know what type of you know data have
been combined in order to help in this
crisis globally or locally well I think
the other example that's the most
pertinent is the mobility data so you
could look at how many trips are are to
the supermarket how many trips are to
government buildings how many trips
there are at the counties and again this
is all collected as aggregate data
usually at the county level and if it's
too sparse then it's not reported but a
lot of economists outside of Google have
been using that data to get estimates of
how the economy is recovering from
shutdowns or what happens when there is
a shutdown etc so that's been quite
useful data and that's all publicly
available so I see Helen has a question
yeah context of question about Google so
there have been comments here about yeah
I get stuff on the other hand they are
you know they opinions say that you know
that they get for the social good you
know
no no prophet intention so what is your
take of that well first of all
the Google and Apple product is not an
app as was earlier it's an API and there
are many many apps built on top of it
from each state can have a different app
each country can have a different app
you can build your own app etc what it's
really doing is it's helping as you
heard this protocol for having quite
private contact tracing without
revealing a lot of data and it's a
modification the operating system to
preserve battery life and a few things
like that so it's really pretty
technical in terms of what it's doing
and I would suspect that it would be
turned off once the once the problem a
base now I don't know there could be
mutation and all sorts of other things
there might be different degrees of
which you would do this but I can tell
you it certainly was not motivated by
any kind of profit motive and I don't
see how you would possibly make profit
off of the API anyway so that's my
that's my understanding of things Thank
You Helen
she may be muted I think you're muted we
cannot hear you
we don't hear you sorry you can ask in
the chat can you okay can you hear me
now yeah yes I just got this money I got
can you hear me yes I got this very
fancy set of headphones Bose everything
noise cancelling but it's way too smart
for me so I apologize now back to the
normal this was just a side check that
was happening that was responsive to
health point about proxy proxy questions
being good for for privacy I forget the
exact way of saying it and I was mindful
of of the reaction which was like do you
know of people instead of do you know
people so I think that that's of
litigation on the other hand hell I
would I would be interested in like
great clarification or clarity on what
you mean because it may be true that
when you ask the question in the way you
do reduce people's privacy shield so is
it is it that the point you're making
that people are less likely to feel
concerned for privacy when you ask it
like and it's more kind of Haverhill
manipulation than actually the fact that
because sometimes when people share
information about others of course they
can compromise other people's privacy as
well right but I think if you think
about my question most people wear a
face mask when they do this the answers
to that are going to differ from region
to region from
the county and my guess is it would be
correlated with various kinds of public
health issues and I think Dierdre raised
a very interesting point in their in her
question maybe the maybe you're getting
a differential response rate because
people feel more comfortable answering
the community question than they feel
answering the family question and I
think that's that's there's certainly a
reasonable hypothesis and of course we
can tell by looking at the data because
there was a period of time where there
was only the family question and then
there was a period when it went to the
community question and we could see what
the response rates how they changed at
that point so if so that would be quite
an interesting phenomenon and it it is
the case that people would generally
feel much more willing to offer opinions
about their community than they would
about their family so you're asking a
less sensitive question I believe most
people would agree with that statement
but the surprise the big surprises it's
it's more it's less sensitive but it's
actually more predictive which was nice
to us that's for sure it's not a
surprise to me like if you look at the
history around kind of public health
endeavors and the relationship between
kind of the sensitivity of the ask and
the kind of utility of the data you see
this happening in all different ways one
of my favorite examples you know when
they were trying to make sure that
people weren't donating blood that had
HIV in it you know they all of a sudden
had to realize that having a human ask
somebody in a workplace a set of
questions about sexual behavior probably
not going to get great answers having a
human even not in the workplace ask a
set of questions wasn't really useful
having a little thing at the end of the
forum that said if there's any reason
that we shouldn't give your blood to
another human please check this box was
a really useful tool for weeding out any
hiv-positive blood because people didn't
have to explain why they didn't have to
just
any sensitive information but they were
able to disclose the fact that they
thought that their blood presented some
risk right and really understanding and
it was like privacy from whom right
privacy from your colleague privacy from
the nurse who was asking the questions
these things really matter in like the
design of the system that don't about
Google is that people ask questions of
Google that they would never ask of a
person and those questions could be very
very important like sexually related
questions and so on
and that's held up in the research
literature to around kids and sexual
health I haven't looked at it recently
but same thing I don't think that we
should merge together the ability to
extract information from people and
whether you're respecting privacy
because you can certainly trick people
into feeling more comfortable about
revealing and you still have to ask the
question of yourself but whether that's
an acceptable question to ask in
exacting that information from them I
think they're tuned and maybe Kobe had
mentioned really there's the ethical
question and then there's the behavioral
manipulation
you know Deirdre I think we're in
agreement on this yeah yeah I was
suggesting that it's a useful hypothesis
potentially for why you get better data
not that it is a good practice although
you might think as a public health
official like we might decide
collectively that it is both privacy
protective and consistent with the
function of the public health system so
it might be that we choose it for that
reason of course there are also
completely innocuous questions that
don't have a privacy component like are
you thinking are you going to are you in
the market for a new car which where
they have uses I was one of the examples
from the proxy questioning if you
rephrase I question you know people that
are in the market for a new car you can
get a better
what the aggregate behavior looks like
in fact I want to go back to what I said
at the very beginning for a lot of these
questions the you don't want the
individual response you want the
aggregate response that's what we're
interested in measuring in economics in
most cases and all those individual
responses are just a nuisance so you
want to try to get rid of them and then
ask something that's actually relevant
for looking at what the macro economy
might be doing there's one more question
but we're out of time so I'll leave the
decision to the organizers to decide
whether you want to continue or not
let's take the last question and then we
conclude that Elliot wanted to ask one
quick question so it's it's a question
for how it's a real quick question it
was really interesting to me that you
just that you indicated that before you
got to the proxy question you had a
question in a survey that was very good
it passed ethics review and privacy
review I'm really curious I was on the
accountability and transparency panel is
anyone from outside Google serving on
those either of those panels and do you
publish any discussion or the decision
or the analysis towards that so this
survey was using this Google product but
the people who owned the survey who are
using the survey were the Carnegie
Mellon people so they passed their
privacy and ethics committees inside
Carnegie Mellon but you could imagine
this is a question where people can go
either way especially because are all of
these warnings that you know prefer not
to answer I'm going to ask you a health
question etc so you do get this some
variation which is Andy because you try
to find out whether response rate
changes depending on how you posed this
question so the it's not done by you all
the review relied on the CMU ethics and
privacy review data so so what happens
is there is this question though should
lead phrase should we ask this question
or should we not and it was it passed
all those hurdles because
of the ability to opt out but people
could opt out however they wanted
nobody's forced to answer the question
anyway so we did we did a cursory we did
an internal review on those issues as
well so but I think we're mean ah do you
want to add something is one of the
organizers is this you're the only
person the organizers that they see on
my screen now I guess for those of us at
the other side of the Atlantic I wish us
a good night and for those of you still
have the day ahead of you enjoy the rest
of the day and we will thank you
everyone for a great discussion today
and we're gonna meet tomorrow at 8:30
for discussing the social justice and
ethical aspects of AI thank you see you
tomorrow